immer noch wie ein kleines kind
so sind mütter halt sie lieb dich eben
sehr das kann sein aber sie klammert so
also wenn meine mutter extra aus
brasilien gekommen wäre um eine wohnung
einzurichten hätte ich mich gefreut von
ist die familie sehr hast du eigentlich
geschwister ja einen bruder und zwei
schwestern und natürlich vermisse ich
sie alle
so
ich hoffe das war jetzt aber der letzte
karton
warum hilft erneut nicht mit na ja ich
gehe zur asse vielen dank
manchmal glaube ich wirklich dass er
lieber mit reeser zusammen ist als mit
mir egal
suchst du was meine entwürfe das für
entwürfe muss bald meine
semesterabschluss arbeit abgeben
meine mutter denkt ja immer noch dass
ich model werden will
dabei hat das studium damit gar nichts
zu tun
die
meine entwürfe nicht dass ich sie alle
verloren habe jetzt bleibt mal ganz
ruhig
die werden schon nicht was es ist
wirklich schon für die 48 ja ich muss
gleich in der kneipe anfang
hattest du nicht gesagt ganz okay
ich bin beim nächsten mal bitte
pünktlich du bist zu spät der gast da
vorne verdurstet schon ein kölsch für
ihn
hier gehen
ich sag mal bist du verrückt du kannst
auch kein kölsch und pils glastafeln
hier menschen musik um
auch und kommst du weiter ja
bei mir ist im moment alles total
kompliziert
ich weiß gar nicht was ich machen soll
was ist denn los
ich finde einfach keinen praktikumsplatz
schon wieder nur absagen
mein erster arbeitstag in der kneipe war
schrecklich und außerdem vermisse ich
lena
magst mir auch keine große hilfe
jetzt erzähle ich schon wieder nur von
meinen problemen dabei hast du doch
selber genug am hals
komm her